ha hecho un trabajo increíble con el
equipo de wiito felicitaciones estuvo
increíble qué opinas de farrell
conozco mucho tiempo es como de la
familia lo quiero es muy y tiene un ojo
increíble siempre lo ha tenido y nunca
ha cambiado desde el primer día que lo
conocí
[Música]
es el acontecimiento de la temporada
sino de la década periodistas de moda
compradores famosos y personas
influyentes de todo el mundo acuden a la
capital francesa para descubrir el
puente más antiguo de París el
engalanado en oro e iluminado con mil
luces deslumbrantes al anochecer la
emoción es palpable ya que la multitud
espera el desfile de moda que pondrá fin
a todos los desfiles de moda
[Música]
inaugura la colección de moda masculina
de verano 2024 este año El director
general de la marca Pietro becari ha
hecho una apuesta Audaz ofrecer las
riendas artísticas a una estrella del
escenario y de la pasarela
extraordinario rapero y diseñador
estadounidense Pharrell Williams
estamos encantados es como un sueño
hecho realidad estamos aquí en el No
creo que esto vuelva a ocurrir pronto
asegurando a punoff es una historia
maravillosa entre farrell Y yo que llega
hoy a su Maravillosa culminación en 2018
era el número 2 de wheaton y ahora que
soy el jefe me puse en contacto con el
de nuevo es maravilloso estamos
encantados muy felices y estamos tan
agradecidos a la alcaldía de París al
gobierno local por permitirnos hacer
esto es una publicidad maravillosa para
París en todo el mundo y qué pasa con
los diseñadores que paulatinamente son
mucho más que simples diseñadores los
diseñadores nacen de la cultura creo que
la gente tiene un verdadero apetito por
las historias maravillosas y esta noche
vamos a ser testigos de una historia
preciosa
[Música]
Pharrell Williams se pone en los zapatos
del fallecido virginidadblo un
visionario de la moda que murió en 2021
sabía que hoy en día la moda no consiste
simplemente en hacer ropa se trata de
contar historias sin olvidar nunca la
importancia de Un diseño excelente y una
calidad impecable bajo la dirección de
Williams ese mismo enfoque perdura ya
que transforma la ropa de calle de
camuflaje en sinónimo de elegancia
moderna
[Música]
Cómo se siente después del espectáculo
otro fanático de la música que se
presenta en París el infatigable joji
yamamoto que cumplirá 80 años este año y
que sigue siendo una estrella
me parece genial inspira mucho y creo
que es la razón por la que es una
leyenda
joji es una leyenda es leyenda y él es
como piensas en los detalles y piensas
en el estilo es tan sencillo y la forma
en que se siente la textura de su ropa
es muy se siente como en casa sabes creo
que es lo que siempre queremos sentirnos
como en casa vayamos donde vayamos
Bueno yo ya soy su fan desde hace tiempo
tuve el placer de ir a su tienda de
osaka por primera vez cuando fui a Japón
y cambió mi visión cambio mi forma de
ver la moda de una manera muy positiva
gracias a joji por hacer este hermoso
arte es una verdadera fuente de
inspiración la invitación enviada para
el desfile de joji yamamoto consistía en
un azulejo de cerámica grabado con su
doble firma y un intrigante mensaje
[Música]
en primer lugar
recibo esta invitación
y está escrito loco
Yo soy una especie de loco tú también
nosotros demasiado locos porque eligió
esta invitación
porque quería la mezcla cosas bellas la
belleza paisajes bellos y paisajes feos
Esto está a la mitad
no hablemos ahora de la colección
hay muchas huellas
ya veo es culpa suya
[Música]
me envió fotos muy antiguas de dibujos
pinturas y construcciones antiguas
[Música]
Así que quise hacer un espectáculo en el
que lo bello y lo feo se unieran
mi última pregunta cómo es la vida Hoy
vamos vamos
cuando me vuelvo relajado como un ser
humano adulto estoy aprendiendo que el
mundo es demasiado complicado
[Música]
hacen una guerra y matan a la gente me
siento triste
[Música]
Así que cuando creo este atuendo para la
gente quiero disfrutar dejar que la
gente disfrute y sea feliz
según algunas Fuentes el desfile del
Louis Vuitton costó 20 millones de euros
con una cobertura mediática mundial
asegurada a joji yamamoto no le cuesta
ni de lejos eso pero así es exactamente
como le gusta